Harry we come now toward the end of our
story we have followed Paul's career in
these last chapters help us under
where we are and where we will be in the
final chapters of the book of Acts right
so Paul has come to Jerusalem as we know
to take to bring a collection there and
that's that glossed over by Luke he
encounters James James makes a proposal
to him that he taken as a right valve go
to the temple that's perceived as an
attempt to profane the temple and causes
a ruckus and Paul is arrested so when we
will ask together Paul was being sent to
the governor Felix who would have known
as a procurator at the time and that's
where we left it so in chapter 24 we
find Paul before that governor Felix at
says areia we're going to see him making
defenses before both Roman and Jewish
authorities in the next several chapters
making an appeal to Rome and being sent
off and acts will conclude with him in
Rome and want to say a little bit more
about that scene so that's where we are
any any themes and the defense's that
you in the defense's you want to hold up
especially yeah if you look at the the
first one of these in in chapter 24 we
hear echos of some things that Paul has
said elsewhere in verse 14 I worship the
god of our ancestors yeah
believing everything lay down according
to the law and or written in the
prophets so this is that theme of
continuity with the Jewish tradition
that Luke insists on all the way through
this is an authentic extension of the
people of Israel this Messianic movement
and there's also eschatological hope
here in verse 15 is the same offense I
have a hope in God so there were
theological points that are being scored
and colorized yeah
these defenses and we'll see a little
bit more of this when Paul gives the
final account of his conversion
experience so there's a lot of
repetition in these last chapters that
pick up themes that we've we've heard
before
Paul is innocent of any kind of crime
against the state Paul stands in
continuity with the best in Jewish
tradition as well as obviously Christian
Jew Yeah right and despite the rejection
by Jews this there's a I think a glimmer
of hope that
the rootage in the Jewish tradition is
going to be something all the long
filters but a little bit of that at
every point there were some some Jews
who accept what Paul is saying I think
that's part of Luke's hopeful message I
do too mm-hmm
and in 26 when in that last defense
before a gripper we get the third
account of the Damascus Road experience
anything new there or is this
reiteration or is it we yeah I think
there's a little bit of reiteration we
got to set the scene a little bit though
okay so Paul has appealed to the Emperor
right and the governor or procurator now
Festus who succeeded Felix sometime in
the late fifties or sixties has a
consultation with the Jewish king this
is herod agrippa ii the son of Herod
Agrippa the first whose death was
reported earlier on in the grandson of
Herod the Great a great great great
grandson of the great so just as in the
gospel there was a pair of hearings
between secular and and religious
authorities yeah so to here we have the
secular Roman Authority and they the
Jewish Authority
King Herod Agrippa ii by the way did not
rule over Jerusalem or over Judea in
some areas we might now think of them
his territory was part of the old
Herodian kingdom in the north okay but
he did still have some rights over
administration of the temple we know
that from Jewish historian Josephus okay
and so it's not at all impossible that
he would have been down and visiting
there's a range where Felix was it was
headquartered there so that's the the
scene that Sarah and Paul defends
himself and before Agrippa and sounds
some of the the themes that have been
sounded when Luke was trying to show the
connection with Jewish tradition he
starts out in chapter 26 verse 5 I
belong to the strictest sect of our
religion lived as a Pharisee that Lucas
insisted on this of all the ways yeah
anything that he says once that he
thinks is important he's going to say
two or three all right
does so here now and he also refers to
hopes and promises that tradition and so
he links himself with with the tradition
in a significant way but insist that
yeah he's he's here because of Jesus of
Nazareth but he hasn't done anything
wrong and he doesn't upset the Roman
apple cart in any way he tells him his
conversion and the story is pretty much
the story we've heard in the two earlier
versions the narrative in Chapter nine
and the other one in chapter twenty two
told by Paul with a couple of
interesting additions and one of those
interesting additions is what Jesus says
to Paul in chapter 26 verse 12 Paul here
has said to report I've heard a voice
saying to me in the Hebrew language and
it says Saul Saul why are you
persecuting me it hurts you to kick
against the goads yeah and that last
phrase is not something refer before
it's a Greek proverb aha and it's a
Greek proverb that works in perfect I am
back been Tabata in in in this line and
and we have it virtually in exactly that
form in a famous play by Euripides The
Bacchae and I think just as there was a
kind of illusion to homer back in the
you tychicus episode I think there's an
allusion to here and The Bacchae is
about someone who resists the divine
will Sariah and Jesus is in effect
telling Paul don't resist that my will
the divine will that's being expressed
to really do what I have for you to do
that is go and bring my word with me to
the Gentiles so Luke I think is being
very clever here for those who pick up
on literary allusion yeah as we've seen
him in doing 17 some other occasions
yeah so and have a having and note how
Luke is playing both sides of the
audience he it he's clearly addressing a
illiterate Greek speaking Greek reading
audience yeah plugging into their
literary traditions he wants to insist
however that
what he is speaking about and the people
who see whom he is defending are plugged
into the jurors no it's actually all the
time yeah and has have Paul defend his
preaching yeah at the end of this this
story you know and do so in words it
sound very very very Jewish so I stand
here testifying to both great and small
saying nothing but what the prophets and
Moses said take place so that scripture
is being fulfilled in this this movement
is a another important theme of Luke and
here it is Paul articulating that and
driving us dead drug repentance and
forgiveness which is where we were in
chapter 2 right right Luke drives that
in again and again and again and and in
the Gospel of Luke one thing that we'll
note as we get into this into these
passages especially in chapter 27 but
it's also been there earlier in the
gospel and in the book of Acts is there
are some passages where the author
writes as we as opposed to they
third-person our first-person plural as
if he were companion of Paul's for all
this what do you make of that as a
that's a really hard arresting acts
strategy that's a really interesting
issue and a lot of ink has been spilled
you know that one idea here is that that
Luke himself was an eyewitness those
parts of Luca whoever wrote Acts that
was an eyewitness of those parts of the
Paul line missionary activity where we
appears right it's possible entirely
possible we can't just prove that
another possibility is that the author
of Acts Luke had access to a diary or
travelogue or something by someone who
was an eyewitness and the third
possibility is that this is purely a
literary device to try to lay claim to I
with the status but my hunch is is
somewhere in the middle that is I I
doubt that the author of Acts was an
eyewitness to much of what went on in
Paul's activity that Paul's missionary
activity I think he might have known
some of the letters of Paul but I think
he probably had access to some
reminiscence as someone who was yeah so
I think he's using saw some time so at
this point and may at some point do some
editorial connection
I in that source material narrative
around the world and then the the trip
to Rome with a great storm at sea in the
shipwreck and when I was a graduate
student this was always the text you had
to translate from Greek into English
because the Greek words were so unusual
what's going on besides Greek testing
here right Luke by the way writes
credible Greek it's out they the highest
literary form but it's a decent Greek
something like that
in any case yeah this is a very gripping
story you know and it's one of the
points in in the narrative of Acts that
a lot of people point to as being most
closely related to popular fiction aha
and they in the current world because a
lot of the romance novels that we know
of have episodes like this where the
hero was subjected to storms and trials
and tribulations by whether one who
knows right so yeah we have a rather
vivid description of a storm at sea Paul
being portrayed in kind of heroic terms
as someone who's not bothered by this
someone who has his trust and confidence
in God and that trust and confidence is
finally vindicated and everybody is
saying after they do a variety of things
to try to save the ship all of which
have some of this technical vocabulary
exactly yeah
so they they finally land by shipwreck
on Malta but they're all safe and sound
all right two big questions with which I
want to end this part of our
conversation and actually end our
conversation for this time and the first
one is this
we have suggested as we've learned from
others too that in many ways this story
reflects the passion story of Christ
that there's trials before Jewish and
Gentile authorities there's imprisonment
there's excitement there's opposition
what there's not is crucifixion or
stoning or any kind of there's no end
there's no end right there is chatting
away and it's all over what's that about
seems like a yes that doesn't finish one
of the mysteries is why after all this
set up we don't have a martyrdom
how do we know the Paul was modern well
we had yeah we have some traditions at
the end of the first century the First
Epistle of Clement probably written from
Rome 9500 somewhere in that range not
much later than this not much later yeah
maybe even contemporary with it that
reports that Peter and Paul were
martyred together a hero so that would
have been about 64 so some people have
have tried to construct a chronology or
life of Paul that has him get out of
Roman imprisonment were any of him at
the end of Acts right and fulfill his
long-standing desire to engage in
missionary activity in Spain Spain and
then come back get martyred I don't
think there's enough time I think he was
imprisoned in accent in the persecution
of Christians under Nero and 64 was
executed and we have later stories about
how that execution took place took place
and that was by beheading right why
didn't Luke tell that story I think for
for his purposes he wanted the
well-rounded narrative mm-hmm and we
have literary theoreticians in the
Hellenistic world who talk about that
and talk about writing history even in
such a way as to have a beginning a
middle and an end
and to have a story told in in a way
that would be uplifting and have a theme
and Luke's theme as you recall at the
beginning of Acts pretty clear it's
about the preaching of the gospel
message and the spread of the gospel
message yeah so that theme reaches its
conclusion when Paul is preaching and
teaching in Rome
yeah and it would be literally anti-gay
yes he was beheaded he was behind even
though I think Luke knows it I think he
assumes that his audience knows it and
he's we don't have the emphasis on
unmodeled him here that we'll have in
moderato g's of the second century right
he's fine to have the Stephen story and
see that as a reminiscence of they the
death of Christ but the important story
from Luke's point of view was the spread
of the gospel very nice and so when that
reaches Rome his tell
is done yeah but then the question
remains that we've been looking at
really in every session the the
complicated question of what happens to
the Jews when the gospel is primarily
preached to the Gentiles and how does
Luke want us to understand the role of
the Jewish people in God's ongoing story
mmm I think there's some ambiguity in
the way Luke concludes his story and
concludes his treatment of that theme in
thinking about how Luke wrestles with
this though I think it's useful to
remove what Paul does because Paul was
confronted with a similar problem and he
wrestles with it with great emotion in
Romans 9 through 11 it talks about the
fact that Jews have not by and large
accepted his understanding of God's work
in Christ and it pains him deeply that
they don't but he also affirms that
God's promises to the Jews and his
election of them is irrevocable and so
there he holds out the hope that
eventually they will see the truth in
his message and says at the end of
toward the end of Romans 11 that all
Israel will be saved so he has a an
optimistic sense based on his
understanding that the Jewish rejection
of his gospel message is part of the
Divine Plan absolutely plan that through
that rejection will stimulate Gentiles
to accept it which in turn will
stimulate Jews to accept it so he has a
hope that all will be won in a messianic
community at the end where they'll be
neither Jew Jew nor Greek I'm not sure
Luke shares all the details of that
eschatological hope or that way of
wrestling with the problem but he does
leave a certain ambiguous set of notes
all the way along he's been emphasizing
the continuity between Paul and his
version of the Christian message and
that the prophets and Moses and
Scripture and pharisaic Judaism and two
of the end he has some interesting
little touches the final episode and the
hearing before Agrippa who has that
question of Agrippa to Paul are you so
quickly persuading me to become a
Christian which can be read again a
couple of ways
Agrippa dismissively rejecting Paul's
appeal to him or leaving them open
yeah yeah about there and then we have
chapter 28 where we see Paul for the
last time in Jerusalem
and he's preaching and teaching and
Jewish leaders have come to him some of
them apparently accept what he has to
say chapter 28 verse 24 someone
convinced but what he said while others
refused to believe so the typical
reaction that we've seen all the way
through some of Paul's religious
confreres accept his message some doubt
Luke has a rather harsh and a judgment
on those who don't and that's the
negative side of this this whole theme
he cites Isaiah which takes to be a word
of the Holy Spirit speaking through the
prophet that the people will indeed
listen but never understand will look
but never perceive their heart has grown
dull their ears a heart of hearing and
they have shut their eyes so these are
the words of Isaiah that Luke applies to
those in his time who from the Jewish
tradition reject his and Paul's gospel
message so this is a rather harsh
critique but it's balanced by that at
that sense that yeah there were some who
do get it and I think Luke holds out a
similar kind of hope to what Paul
expresses in Romans 11 that eventually
all will get it but he doesn't lay a say
it as easily yeah yeah I think Luke is
so carefully constructed his narrative
that it would be amazing if in the last
two paragraphs he took away all the
signs of hope he'd given us before so I
think we'll end with hope let's do thank
you